my opponent tonight is the wu-tang
clan's Lamont you got Hawkins his new
book is called raw and that's exactly
how all it conduct this interview raw
I'm going to give it to him with no
trivia raw like cocaine straight from
Bolivia come on you got Hawkins
everybody all right you God
golden arms the 4-bar killer you have
many nicknames many nicknames did you
ever want to be the five-barred killer
why are you the 4-bar killer I don't
know they gave that name to me this is
branded me with a name cuz you get a
give four bars in the song you know this
account as a character count thing 25
years ago
enter the 36 chambers yes yes yes when
you look back on that what jumps out
what jumps out the travel the amount of
work you put in you know just meeting a
lot of new people and different people
we come from you know just just being
universal going from small to be a
universal mind that's all yeah like
looking back on that is it is it all
sunny do you see it in all a positive
light sore yes I do because I could have
been dead in the streets yeah yeah will
you talk a little bit about that with in
your new book here yeah that journey to
like what do you see if you didn't find
the wu-tang clan what did you see your
life addict oh I probably would have
been a statistic maybe you know like so
many of my people probably been in jail
trying to figure things out yeah and
there's somehow another probably gets
hired to jail and got me a regular job
or I found the way some we had fun
the way you said even before finding rap
you were trying out a bunch of different
professions and you even studied
becoming an embalmer yes yes really
you're a high schooler thinking about
becoming into Balmer well it wasn't in
high school was in college cuz um I was
real good in science that was a mark I
was always my thing I mean so I was
doing business management at BMCC that
got boring so I was like you know let me
transfer over to LaGuardia to do do do
do I trust trying to try some different
that's a job that's always gonna be
around yes you're touring right now with
the the wu-tang clan yes what's it like
getting back together with ever
about it well it's it's like clockwork
you know I built up with my brothers
literally I've been with my brother
since our like five six years old
mm-hmm so I don't know I don't know how
many people to say they still around the
people they literally grow up with yeah
so it's just like reoccurrence you know
be getting back together with your
family yeah you say you've gone through
a lot of different phases of blue Tang
Clan you've said at times it felt like a
group and at times it started to feel
like a dictatorship which is something
I'm sure Americans don't understand
whatsoever how is that experience well
you know you grow and you learn and you
live and you know and the people that
are in charge you know they grow to also
and hope you know hopefully do the child
and tribulation you know softens the
heart a little bit you know that's
basically what it is you know yeah now
you're performing when you're bringing
36 chambers back out it's it's a
different time 25 years yes later yeah
you're playing giant festivals tens of
thousands of people are there singing
along to songs you guys wrote 25 years
ago about life on the streets own your
own personal experiences and you're
having young kids chant them in stadiums
yes yes is that how you did you ever
envision it that way is that how the
wu-tang is meant to be experienced no
what we got asked to be just ask that
question all the time well sorry I don't
they're not all original I'm sorry
my golden arms come on Kimmy we get
asked that question a few bars give me
four bars the leeway yeah now we didn't
know it was gonna be like this but we
just put a lot of work in you don't
realize how much work you put in
so you into a project or two you put
your life's working and you know just
travel and you just traveled and
shoulders into shows and and and
somewhere along the line it just clicks
you know it's just that's what happened
you know and America just embraced us do
you think they youth do they understand
the wu-tang oh I think they go to us to
get the foundation of what they went
around with you know me I really think
we like the core of hip-hop ya know the
core the hardcore the hardcore yes I'll
give it to you rock
what I thought interesting about your
book you talk about you show some
vulnerability in this book not that
vulnerable not another time no no no
yeah but it's me but there's a little
bit of vulnerability talking about like
performing and finding your voice and
coming in rusty is showing vulnerability
I thought that was a weakness for a
rapper well they won't say certain
things you know as you grow older you
know you find out those things is really
not that big of a deal you know before
oh you never smile and pitches I be like
this all the time
any pictures be like this that's it but
now I'm like this you grow so you know
throw that's the evolution you got tell
me something I already know
with wu-tang stands for woody
unpredictable talent and natural game
that's right
yes I already do matches right Lamont
you got the W right there everybody this
book raw is out now these new album
come on you got Hawkins the fight to
tell you
[Music]